>>> THERE'S BREAKING NEWS TODAY
IN THE SEARCH FOR BRIAN
LAUNDRIE, THE FLORIDA MAN
MISSING SINCE SHORTLY AFTER THE
DEATH OF HIS FIANCEE, GABBY
PETITO.
RANDI KAYE IS WORKING THE STORY
FOR US.
THE FBI JUST A LITTLE WHILE AGO
CONFIRMING LAUNDRIE'S REMAINS
HAD BEEN RECOVERED ALONG WITH
SOME OTHER POTENTIALLY IMPORTANT
EVIDENCE.
WHAT ARE YOU LEARNING?
>> WELL, WOCLF, IT'S BEEN MORE
THAN FIVE WEEKS SINCE HE
DISAPPEARED FROM HIS HOME.
HE LEFT JUST TWO DAYS AFTER
GABBY WAS REPORTED MISSING AND
NOW AFTER THAT EXHAUSTIVE
SEARCH, WE HAVE LEARNED,
FINALLY, THAT THE REMAINS FOUND
HERE JUST YESTERDAY HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED AS BRIAN LAUNDRIE.
THE FBI IDENTIFYING THE HUMAN
REMAINS AS BRIAN LAUNDRIE AFTER
COMPARING DENTAL RECORDS.
>> THIS IS TRAGIC.
>> ONE DAY AFTER THE REMAINS OF
LAUNDRIE WERE FOUND IN A
SOUTHWEST FLORIDA RESERVE,
INVESTIGATORS RETURNED TO
FURTHER SEARCH THE AREA TODAY
AMID TREACHEROUS CONDITIONS.
>> WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WATER
LEVELS UP ABOVE ALMOST THE CHEST
AREA.
RATTLESNAKES.
MOCCASINS.
ALLIGATORS.
YOU JUST CAN'T WALK UP AND LOOK.
IT'S NOT LIKE YOU'RE SEARCHING A
HOUSE OR A CAR.
THESE AREAS ARE HUGE AND THEY'RE
COVERED BY WATER.
>> A SOURCE CLOSE TO THE
INVESTIGATION TELLS CNN THE
REMAINS APPEAR TO HAVE BEEN
THERE A WHILE.
CLOTHING BELIEVED TO BE
LAUNDRIE'S WAS FOUND AS WELL.
LAUNDRIE, WHO HAD NOT BEEN
CHARGED IN THE DEATH OF HIS
FIANCEE, WAS LAST SEEN SEPTEMBER
13th WHEN HE WENT HIKING IN THE
CARLTON NATURE RESERVE, HIS
FAMILY SAID.
THE REMAINS FOUND YESTERDAY WERE
IN THE CARLTON RESERVE, ABOUT A
45-MINUTE WALK.
OFFICIALS SAY BELONGINGS WERE
FOUND BY HIS FATHER.
>> IT'S QUITE SAD, YOU CAN
IMAGINE, AS A PARENT, FINDING
YOUR SON'S BELONGINGS ALONGSIDE
THEM REMAINS.
AND THAT'S GOT TO BE
HEARTBREAKING AND I CAN TELL YOU
THAT THEY ARE HEARTBROKEN.
>> BUT THERE ARE QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHEN AND WHERE THE REMAINS WERE
FOUND.
INCLUDING THE CIRCUMSTANCES OF
YESTERDAY'S SEARCH THAT INVOLVED
HIS PARENTS, ROBERTA AND CHRIS
LAUNDRIE.
THE AREA HAD BEEN UNDERWATER
UNTIL RECENTLY AND ONLY REOPENED
TO THE PUBLIC YESTERDAY.
>> AS THEY WENT FURTHER IN,
CHRIS VENTURED OFF THE TRAIL
INTO THE WOODS, HE WAS
ZIGZAGGING IN DIFFERENT AREAS.
LAW ENFORCEMENT WAS DOING THE
SAME THING.
AT SOME POINT, CHRIS LOCATES
WHAT'S CALLED A DRY BAG.
IT'S A WHITE BAG LAYING IN THE
WOODS, I'LL SAY 20 FEET OR SO
OFF THE TRAIL.
ACCORDING TO CHRIS, IT WAS IN
SOME BRAMBLE.
>> THE PERSONAL ITEMS INCLUDE A
BACKPACK AND NOTEBOOK, BUT SO
FAR, THE CONTENTS HAVE NOT BEEN
REVEALED.
LAUNDRIE DISAPPEARED MORE THAN A
MONTH AGO.
WEDNESDAY, THE FBI CALLED HIM A
PERSON OF INTEREST IN THE
KILLING OF PETITO.
ON SEPTEMBER 1st, LAUNDRIE
RETURNED TO HIS PARENTS' HOME IN
FLORIDA WITHOUT PETITO AFTER
THEIR SUMMER ROAD TRIP.
HER REMAINS WERE LATER FOUND IN
WYOMING.
HER DEATH RULED A HOMICIDE.
AND NOT LONG AFTER THOSE REMAINS
WERE IDENTIFIED AS BRIAN
LAUNDRIE, LAW ENFORCEMENT WENT
TO THE HOME OF CHRIS AND ROBERTA
LAUNDRIE, WHERE BRIAN USED TO
LIVE WITH GABBY PETITO, HIS
FIANCEE, AND ALERTED THEM THAT
YES, INDEED, THOSE REMAINS DID
BELONG TO THEIR SON.
ONE OTHER NOTE, WOLF.
YOU HEARD THE ATTORNEY THERE
MENTION THIS DRY BAG.
I'M TOLD BY A SOURCE CLOSE TO
THE INVESTIGATION THAT NEAR THAT
DRY BAG IS WHERE THAT NOTEBOOK
WAS FOUND.
I'M TOLD THAT IT WAS QUITE WET,
BUT THEY BELIEVE IT IS POSSIBLY
SALVAGEABLE.
THEY'RE GOING TO TRY AND DRY IT
OUT AND SEE WHAT'S INSIDE OF IT.
BUT THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT IN
CASE BRIAN DID WRITE ANYTHING
DOWN ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED TO
GABBY, HOW SHE ENDED UP DEAD.
CERTAINLY THE FAMILY AND MANY
OTHERS ARE GOING TO WANT
SENTENCES.
>> RANDI, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET'S GET MORE ON THIS.
JOINING US NOW, FORENSIC
PATHOLOGIST AND DEPUTY DIRECTOR,
ANDREW McCABE.
ANDREW, CAN YOU WALK US THROUGH
THE FBI'S ROLE IN IDENTIFYING
THESE REMAINS AS BRIAN LAUNDRIE?
WHAT RESOURCES DID THE FBI
DEVOTE TO THIS EFFORT?
>> WELL, WOLF, THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT THIS IS A CASE
THAT'S BEEN GIVEN ALL THE
RESOURCES IT COULD POSSIBLY
NEED.
IN TERMS OF THIS CURRENT IT
RATION OVER THE LAST 24 HOURS OR
SO, I'M QUITE SURE THAT THE
LOCAL MEDICAL EXAMINER WAS THE
PERSON WHO CONDUCTED THE EXAM OF
THE REMAINS, BUT THE FBI CAN BE
VERY HELPFUL IN TERMS OF GETTING
THE EITHER DNA SAMPLES OR DENTAL
RECORDS AND THOSE SORTS OF
THINGS TO THE MEDICAL EXAMINER
FOR THE PURPOSE OF COMPARING
WITH THE SAMPLE, THE EVIDENCE
THEY RECOVER ON THE SCENE.
SO THERE'S ALSO A COORDINATION
PIECE HERE BETWEEN THE
INVESTIGATION THAT'S STILL
ONGOING OUT IN WYOMING.
LET'S NOT FORGET THAT WE HAVE A
HOMICIDE THAT WAS COMMITTED IN A
NATIONAL PARK.
SO FEDERAL LAND IN WYOMING.
AND I'M QUITE SURE THE FBI'S
STILL ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT EXACTLY WHO KILLED
GABBY PETITO.
>> THE FBI USED DENTAL RECORDS
TO IDENTIFY LAUNDRIE.
HOW COMPLICATED IS THAT PROCESS?
>> YEAH, I MEAN, IF YOU HAVE
GOOD X-RAYS FROM BEFORE, IT'S
QUITE DOABLE TO MAKE A
COMPARISON.
IT'S VISUAL.
AND ONCE YOU HAVE THOSE NEXT TO
EACH OTHER, YOU CAN DO IT PRETTY
RAPIDLY.
>> YOU KNOW, ANDREW, WE JUST
HEARD RANDI KAYE REPORT THAT THE
NOTEBOOK RECOVERED AT THE SCENE
MIGHT BE SALVAGEABLE.
WHAT INFORMATION MIGHT
INVESTIGATORS BE ABLE TO GLEAN
FROM THAT DISCOVERY?
>> IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT,
WOLF, THAT THE EVIDENCE RECOVERY
AGENTS AND OTHER TECHNICIANS ON
THE SCENE RECOVER THAT EVIDENCE
IN A WAY THAT PRESERVES IT FOR
EXPLOITATION BACK AT THE LAB.
I WOULD EXPECT THAT MOST OF
THOSE ARTICLES HAVE BEEN TAKEN
OR WILL BE FLOWN TO THE FBI LAB
IN QUANTICO, VIRGINIA, WHERE WE
HAVE EXPERTS WHO REALLY SPEND
THEIR CAREERS DOING THINGS LIKE
DRYING OUT PAPER EVERIDENCE,
TRYING TO RECOVER THE WRITING
AND THE INK MARKS AND
POTENTIALLY FINGERPRINTS AND ALL
SORTS OF OTHER POTENTIALLY
RELEVANT PIECES OF EVIDENCE FROM
AN ARTICLE JUST LIKE THIS.
IN TERMS OF UNDERSTANDING
LAUNDRIE'S MOTIVE, HIS FEELINGS
ABOUT PETITO, MAYBE EVEN YOU
KNOW, ANY KIND OF NOTES OR
COMMENTS THAT HE MAY HAVE MADE
ABOUT THE EVENTS WE'RE STILL
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND IN WYOMING,
THAT NOTEBOOK COULD SHED A LOT
OF LIGHT ON ALL THOSE ISSUES.
>> DO THE LAUNDRIE PARENTS,
THEIR INVOLVEMENT IN THE SEARCH
AT ALL AFFECT SUSPICIONS THAT
ARE OUT THERE NOW?
>> I THINK THE LAUNDRIE FAMILY
HAS CONDUCTED THEMSELVES IN A
FAIRLY ODD WAY THAT'S GENERATED
A LOT OF SUSPICIOUS RIGHT FROM
THE BEGINNING, RIGHT?
THERE'S THE OH, HE LEFT ON THE
14th.
NO, IT TURNS OUT HE LEFT ON THE
13th.
THERE'S BEEN ALL KINDS OF
SUSPICIONS ABOUT THAT.
CHRIS LAUNDRY YESTERDAY, THAT'S
ALL KNOWN TO THE INVESTIGATORS.
SO IT MAY BE ENTIRELY
COINCIDENCE THAT HE CAME ACROSS
HIS SON'S REMAINS AND ARTICLES
OF CLOTHING AND THINGS.
THAT COULD BE THE CASE AS THE
AREA WAS RECENTLY SUBMERGED IN
WATER, BUT WE HAVE TO LEAVE IT
UP TO THE INVESTIGATORS.
>> AS A FORENSIC PATHOLOGIST,
WHAT STOOD OUT TO YOU?
>> YEAH, I MEAN, USUALLY EVEN
WHEN I RESPOND TO A CRIME SCENE,
THE FAMILY IS NOT ALLOWED.
NO EXTERNAL PEOPLE ARE ALLOWED
OTHER THAN THE IMMEDIATE, YOU
KNOW, INVESTIGATORS.
SO THAT WAS ODD TO ME.
BUT IN THIS CASE, I DO BELIEVE
THAT THE TWO MAJOR ISSUES AGAIN
ARE IDENTIFICATION, WHICH HAS
BEEN COMPLETED, AND NOW MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE QUITE A
CHALLENGE IN DETERMINING THE
CAUSE OF DEATH.
YOU KNOW, I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH
HAS BEEN RECOVERED.
OF HIS BODY.
SO THAT WILL BE CHALLENGING.
I KNOW THEY WERE OUT THERE AGAIN
TODA